No state has a right to exist.
Not the Soviet Union,
not Czechoslovakia,
not the Zionist
apartheid state of Israel.
A lot of people think that the phrase
from the river to the sea is racist and anti Semitic.
Do you? Are there really a lot of people?
I appreciate that.
A lot of people in the media bubble,
in the political class,
who at least pretend to, uh.
But what is objectionable about people being free
between our river and the sea?
Jewish people think it's intimidatory.
Well, they think it's.
Not the Jewish people.
Not the Jewish people
on the demonstrations for Gaza chanting it.
Some Jewish people say that they find it,
uh, these things.
But it. Is that something worth respecting?
Uh, no, because the Palestinians have a right to be free.
And they have a right to be free
between the river and the sea.
Now, if you're really asking me what should be the final,
uh, state of affairs in Israel Palestine,
well, my. My position is quite well known.
I think there should be one democratic
and secular state between the river and the sea.
And if I was doing the marketing,
I'd call it the Holy Land.
So you don't want Israel to exist? Oh,
no state has a right to exist.
Not the Soviet Union,
not Czechoslovakia,
not the Zionist
apartheid state of Israel.
I believe that the best solution
for everybody is as it was in South Africa.
Freed from apartheid,
A democratic state
where white people and black people choose Christians,
Muslims live as equal citizens under the law.
That's what I believe.
I appreciate you don't believe it
and that there are others who don't believe it,
but it's a legitimate view.
It's one that has already been a judged
in law in Britain to be a legitimate one,
and I hold it,
and I got a mandate for it tonight.